the World Health Organization is now
calling the monkey pox outbreak a public
health emergency the virus spreads
mainly through skin to skin contact and
can cause a fever and a rash so far the
majority of the cases have happened in
men who were intimate with other men but
officials stress this anyone anyone can
get this virus there are more than
sixteen thousand reported cases around
the world in this country the virus has
appeared in almost every state with
nearly 2 900 cases so far but for now
officials here are stopping short of
calling the spread a public health
emergency here's what the White House
covered response coordinator that's Dr
Ashish Shaw told Face the Nation
yesterday
right now we have over 2000 cases but we
have ramped up vaccinations ramped up
treatments ramped up testing and we're
going to continue to look at all sort of
policy options
but is that enough critics including a
group of 50 house Democrats say the
Biden administration's approach to
combating this virus is inadequate as
vaccine demand has outplayed has
outpaced rather the supply former FDA
commissioner that Scott Gottlieb warned
that monkey pox could soon become
endemic and he says that would be among
the most unfortunate Public Health
failures in recent times